- [Voiceover] In the last
video we took a guess at what
the solution was for our
differential equation and we came
up with an exponential as
our guess and as we did the
analysis we developed a
characteristic equation.
We ended up with a complex
answer for one of the
adjustable parameters, the
natural frequency of our circuit.
So here's the form of
our proposed solution,
now this is getting kinda
complicated but I promise you
we're gonna simplify this pretty soon.
We have two solutions for s, s
one and s two that we plugged
in as plus and minus j omega naught,
and we have more adjustable
amplitude parameters that we
have to figure out.
So now in this video we're
gonna continue on solving our
differential equation, this
is our proposed solution,
this is a pretty complicated
looking expression and
what we're gonna call on
here now is something really
important in electronics and
in general and it's called
Euler's Identity.
And we're gonna use this
identity to figure out what to do
with these complex exponential terms.
So if you search on this term
on Kahn Academy you'll find
an explanation of where
these identities come from
but I'm just gonna state 'em right here.
And what it says is that
Euler's identitiy is
e to the j x anything up
there equals cosign x plus j
times sine x, that's one of the identities
and the other identity is
e to the minus j x equals
cosign of x minus j sine x.
So these are useful because
we have this exponential
function with the complex
unit inside of it,
when we go over to this side,
this is sort of a normal complex number,
cosign x is some number
between plus and minus one,
sine x is some number
and it's just a normal complex number
so this may help us
simplify our life here as we
move forward.
So that's a really important
identity that we get to use
to solve our LC circuit.
Now I'm gonna go back and
rewrite these two exponential's
using Euler's Identity here.
This is gonna get big but it'll
collapse down pretty soon.
Okay, let me move over here,
i equals k one times e to the
plus j omega t let's use this
one here so that would be
cosign x is omega naught t
plus j sine x is omega naught t
and we use the first one.
Okay, now the second term is
plus k two times now we have
the negative up in the
exponent so we use this one
cosign omega naught t minus
j sine omega naught t.
Now we have our solution spread
all out across the screen
and let's see if we can
tidy things up here.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna gather all the cosign
terms together, this one and this one
and then I'll gather
the sine terms together.
Okay so i equals cosign omega
naught t, and the cosign is
multiplied by k one
and plus k two alright.
Now let's add to that
we have j sine and j sine so
I'll write sine omega naught t
over here and j times what,
j times k one and this time
we have this minus sign
that makes it minus k two,
alright so now, current is
some number times cosign plus
j times some number times sine.
Now these are two arbitrary
constants and I'm just gonna
make up another one, I'm
just call this one a one
we'll call this one a
two and we'll call that,
I'll use the j, k one minus k two,
now I can rewrite this
as i equals a one cos mega naught t
plus a two sine omega naught t, good.
So from now on we're
gonna work with these a's
and if I ever want to know
what the original k's were
I would just come back
to these equations here,
once I figure out a, I can
figure out both the k's.
So let's keep pressing on,
how do we figure out a one and a two?
Well to do that we're gonna
use the initial conditions,
the ic's.
And if we think back we
remember that in our original
schematic we had some q
here which means we had a
plus or minus v zero, v
naught, and we said the current
through here started at zero.
So that's our initial conditions,
v of time equals zero equals v naught
and current of time
equals zero equals zero.
Let's use these two values
to help us figure out what
a one and a two are.
And we'll do that in the
next video as we continue the
derivation of the natural response.